this week on forward cnn anchor and
author of the new book lincoln and the
fight for peace john avlon john avalon's
on forward this week
[Music]
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podcast the author of the tremendous
book lincoln and the fight for peace
one of the most independent journalists
that's out there a friend of mine from
cnn john avlon welcome john thanks man
andrew it's good to see you as always
you and i do have kind of a mind meld on
politics i know we're gonna have fun on
this one yeah you are maybe one of the
most died in the wool capital i
independents that i know where you've
actually been ahead of everyone
including me
on the democracy reform train uh how the
heck did you get there before the rest
of us
i mean i appreciate that i don't know
that i can i can take all the credit but
but i i i you know your kind words i'm
not sure i deserve i guess what i'm
saying but i did write
uh my first book was called independent
nation uh how the vital center can
change american politics which was
published in 2004 when i was you know i
think i just turned 30. but um uh
you know it it always seemed common
sense to me
that um when you study
american history and you study the
presidents as i did and love doing so
from a young as a young child
that their parties faded away
the the the party label didn't matter
what mattered were were their ability to
unite and confront the challenges of the
time and that necessarily you know in
the pendulum swing of american politics
as used to be it necessarily didn't
follow the pattern of any one political
party
and um and even then things were getting
more and more extreme you know party
polarization in congress you saw really
hit overdrive after 1994 with the
republican revolution and bill clinton
re-centered the democrats after the
democrats lost three consecutive
elections by 40 states bill clinton
moved the democratic party to the center
and was able to win back the white house
and and and you know it just seemed to
be very obviously that if you seize the
center if you try to realign politics if
you don't focus on playing to the base
that that's where most american people
are but there's a huge disconnect
between where the politicians are and
where the most activist base is and and
where the heart and soul the country is
and and then what we saw over recent
decades this attempt and you and i have
discussed this and you know this is
chapter and verse for you this attempt
to rig the system to
perpetuate this false notion that
america is ideologically polarized so
they do it through the rigged system of
redistricting and close partisans and
primaries and all the things that you've
been
hammering out on to basically move power
to the extremes of our politics and so
you reap what you sow
and and so we have a politics that ends
up denigrating our democracy by giving
people false choices and and i want to
be clear right now we have asymmetric
polarization the republican party is far
more further to the right than the
democratic party is for the left so this
is not a both sides and critique but
that dynamic ends up running down our
democracy by perpetuating division
dysfunction and then a kind of cynicism
that makes some people think there's no
functional difference between democracy
and other forms of government uh
although i think they've gotten a
reality check so to speak in in recent
weeks about the fundamental differences
so you've been a student of history
since way back if you were writing about
the stuff in essentially your 20s uh is
it somehow an accident that you ended up
marrying the descendant of one of the
presidents were you like screening when
you were dating being like are you
are you the descendant of a u.s
president
check
that would be so creepy and and
sociopathic and and for all my many
faults i don't think that's one of them
uh no i i think was probably an added
point of interest
although it's fair to say that um
uh i i was not a a uh a student of
herbert hoover or had a a particularly
sympathetic view of him before i met
margaret and i learned a lot actually
about what an extraordinary uh american
he was and that's not only because i'm
married to margaret
uh no that that was a um
a happy coincidence i think if you look
at the qualities i was looking for at
the time rooted in her personality
having absolutely nothing to do with
their last name
you know you would have seen really
quickly uh that she is my type in in
every way
and neither and neither by the way uh
you know given the fact that she was a
republican a conservative it was
actually an issue we've we've talked
about this you know the fact that i was
independent was a real challenge for her
and her family you know there was an
assumption that that's it yeah you know
that there's an assumption i mean party
identity had sort of not supplanted the
role of religion but had an almost
religious uh quality particularly in
that family and and somewhat honestly
earned given the scar tissue they had
because the partisan fights although
ironically herbert hoover when he was
elected described himself as an
independent progressive in the
republican tradition which i love and i
remind my father in love whenever i can
but yeah so even that was a that was
that was a hurdle in our in our
courtship so to speak
wow fascinating um well for those of you
who don't know john's married to
margaret hoover who's an awesome
journalist in her own right and both
john and margaret were some of the most
generous journalists when i was running
for office where they brought me on just
to talk about the ideas i was running on
as opposed to the usual
stuff so was always very grateful to
both you and margaret and like having
been on margaret's program i actually
would have no inkling as to what her
political
uh self-identification is which i think
is how a lot of people would uh you know
would like to to
interact with people so hats off to to
both of you uh
um reading this book was
fascinating uh and engrossing and it
made me think as someone who's written a
book or two this book seems
extraordinarily hard to write
in the sense that you're like recreating
historical seeds it's like you know
lincoln and his son tad walking through
this town i'm like how the heck
does one go about even
uh
getting all the primary material to
write a book like this
well i mean you know first of all you
write it because you love it and it's a
different pace from what you do day to
day i mean you know i began as a
speechwriter then i was a columnist
then i became editor-in-chief for the
daily beast which is when i met you
uh and now as an anchor and analyst you
know writing a a book particularly a
history book is a is a different speed
it um and and in the case of the opening
the book which is lincoln's walk into
richmond um day two days after after the
the capital the confederacy fell holding
his son tad's hand on the boy's 12th
birthday i actually took my son and we
recreated the walk uh up from the river
to the top of capitol hill yeah wow and
um
and and you're able to get a sense of
bearings and there's a remarkable park
ranger there michael gorman who wrote a
90-page essay about lincoln richmond
that debunked a lot of myths and did the
walk with him and learned from him and
toured um you know the confederate white
house jefferson davis's capital
home and where where lincoln sat and
where he met everybody on that day so
you know there's primary research and
then sometimes there's physical research
which i love um but you know it it you
know a column or reality check will take
me four or five hours to write this took
me just over four years to write but you
want to get the music right there was a
lot of painstaking
uh detail
and i just imagined you being like
surrounded by
various documents and manuscripts
i'll say i've got pictures i mean one
point jack is reading my son jack is
reading a a tiny uh a little little for
a kid's book on abraham lincoln and
behind him are two tall stacks of books
about abraham lincoln you know and uh oh
yeah i mean the
the the the research and the research is
part of the fun to the extent where i
don't know if you ever ever have this
experience where um you think you're
writing when you're doing the research
then you realize that you know you
really don't start writing until you
actually start writing it's necessary to
kind of get the ideas you can convince
yourself uh you're doing all sorts of
things when you're uh preparing to write
my friend like
that's true
it's true
[Music]
uh so
you started this book years ago um but i
have to say it seemed very very relevant
to today
and i think the thing that is stunning
was stunning to me
was that abraham lincoln was essentially
a third-party candidate
uh he he was kind of a nobody uh up to
that when he was like a former one-term
member of congress rattling around the
midwest
uh and then there is this uh new startup
party called the republican party that
just kind of comes out of nowhere
yeah and
and he wins a four-way race yeah
39.8 of the vote and just as someone you
know grows up in this country venerating
abraham lincoln like i was like what
no i i you know and i i totally
understand why you uh would gravitate to
that part and i i actually originally
that section was two or three times as
long because i got into like the real
like electoral mechanics of how the whig
party was supplanted by the republican
party which you're right it's the most
successful third party in american
history um and there's a lot to learn
from it people think that you know
it's important to remember for folks
that you know our constitution doesn't
mention political parties it does
mention journalists i like to point out
but it doesn't mention political parties
that's because the founding fathers
which was my last book is about
washington's farewell
he was an independent as a matter of
principle uh the founding fathers
expected that members of congress would
represent their conscience and their
constituents but not through the filter
of party
eventually within their lifetime they
realized that was perhaps inevitable but
you know the the democrat the federalist
party is supplanted by the wig party
which then falls apart fails to take a
stand on slavery that's distinct and
clear the defining issue of the time uh
then there's an anti-immigrant
know-nothing party that emerges that
lincoln refuses to join although it's
the first nativist party that you know
is very resonant today and in the way
the republican party is created and how
quickly it rises it's a big tent
moderate progressive party dedicated to
opposing slavery some people oppose its
expansion some people want complete
abolition um and it really ends up
seeding the states of the fastest
growing areas the upper midwest and and
the northeast
and lincoln
after losing a senate race but his
speeches uh against slavery were in
slavery's expansion were so powerful
that he developed a national reputation
is sort of this young fresh-faced
compromised candidate he's the moderate
from the midwest
and he has a reputation for honesty and
he's not seen as a radical
as i say he's a reconciler in a time of
radicals and reactionaries and that
rockets him up to to lead the nation at
the start of the civil war without any
executive experience and no military
experience and one term in congress
and and he succeeds because of his
character and because of his capacity to
grow and it's a reminder that you know
the study of history
you know shows very clearly i think that
character is the single most important
quality of the president
bar
barton
most successful third party indeed uh so
the republican party starts out as a
northern anti-slave party which uh is
not the way most people think of it
today i mean it's kind of reversed rules
in terms of dominar south
um
thanks to
uh the civil rights act the the 1960s
so lincoln becomes president and that
almost immediately kicks off the civil
war in essence because there are
there there were candidates who were
vying for
uh
for votes in the south neither of whom
was abraham lincoln uh and then when
lincoln won with essentially
uh exclusively northern support then the
south uh decides to secede shortly
thereafter and lincoln finds himself a
wartime president with as you described
very limited experience in that realm
yeah and and you know it he wins
actually the the the states in the
pacific california oregon and i believe
washington at that point certainly
california and oregon but they have you
know they they have incredibly small
populations uh
and and but you're right it's it's the
energy in the country is was in the
upper midwest and the northeast and
that's what he wins and he lincoln
doesn't even appear on the ballot
in the deep south um and and what you
see also is that the the planter class
the slave owners who are pushing
secession
never dared initially bring it to a
popular vote in the states they tried to
do it in closed partisan uh conventions
and then they they relied on the
essentially the violence uh beginning
with the focus on on fort sumter um that
feeling they knew the feeling of
resentment and revenge would create its
own kind of remorseless logic and people
thought well we'll just have a quick war
and get this over with but of course
that's not what happened
and and lincoln who really is a man of
peace in a time of war
um is the least likely guy but he he
studies quickly he develops a theory of
of war and he relies on his
interpersonal absence of malice you know
the the defining characteristics i see
you know he's he's temperamentally a
moderate man but he combines moderation
with moral courage and i think that's
something that that you and i share and
focus on is is that that's that that's
the magic combination that too often is
missing
too many people look at moderates and
see an absence of moral courage
intuitive people with moral courage
assume a sense of moral superiority and
that's not the way to persuade people
democracy depends on persuasion and even
in the middle of a civil war what's so
extraordinary is that lincoln still
believes that there's more than unites
us than divides us he refuses to
demonize people he disagreed with yes
even when they're calling for his death
he believes that you empathize with your
opponents as a means of reasoning with
them
it's the politics of the golden rule and
i think it's so inspiring and it was
unusual in his time too don't get me
wrong
uh but but it is it's the reason he's on
a higher level than any president or any
american political figure
yeah this is a quote that i feel like
everyone should take to heart there are
so many lincoln quotes uh in this book
that i was reminded of uh but here's
here's one that spoke to me if you would
win a man to your cause first convince
him you are his sincere friend
but mark him as one to be shamed and
despised he will retreat within himself
close all avenues to his head and his
heart
and i think that's totally true
it's totally true
it seems like like that that's a
fundamental lesson that everyone just is
completely ignored nowadays well it is
and and this is something that you get
grief for sometimes in a good good good
faith attempt to reach out and empathize
with people and hear where they're
coming from
and in in the current environment
you know that basic quality of empathy
let's be honest has been strained
it's difficult in in environments
you know where people are believing a
self-evident big lie bush by a con man
who tried to overturn an election
that's going to strain our capacity for
empathy when you see people doubling
down on that
but if lincoln could
continue with that spirit of empathy
even the middle of the civil war when he
he would not demonize people disagrees
with in public or private
you know that that's a that's a that's a
that's a tall order that's a that's a
big example but but it really isn't
coming upon us to try we may miss that
mark
but but it really is incumbent upon us
for try because that's how we get out of
this ultimately you know i mean every
knowledge of human nature would suggest
that and and and all the
the the emotional reflexes and politics
are
set up the other way but we're gonna
need to find a way to transcend that to
reconcile again and and so i know that
you understand that dynamic oh he
literally had people threatening his
life and he would say uh it's okay like
we we'd be doing the same thing in their
shoes that sounds like just an
incredible attitude
yeah
it's remarkable especially when you see
how he combines he combines opposites
and and he does you know he personally
swings between tragedy and comedy
and and depression and
this sort of you know tendency to tell
jokes all the time which is really a
form of self-medication for him but
which leads other people his
contemporaries to accuse him of being
insufficiently serious
um you know there's that story early in
the book where after a brutal union
defeat
um his friend isaac and arnold the
congressman from illinois goes to visit
him in the white house and he's sitting
on the second floor in front of a
fireplace and he's reading from a book
of his favorite humorist artemis and
ward and it ward like another of his
favorites petroleum v nasby play
characters i mean it's actually a very
it's like it's satire it's first person
satire and the kind of way that the
original stephen colbert show did
uh where they're playing a character
anyway arnold
sees him laughing by the fireplace after
this brutal union defeat and he's
furious at his friend he says what the
hell are you doing how can you laugh at
a time like this
and then in arnold's uh
memoir he he describes lincoln as
throwing down the book and turning to
him with tears in his eyes and saying do
you not realize that if i could not find
some way to get relief that my heart
would break
and that's when he realized that the
laughter and the storytelling and the
joking was a form of self-medication
which i think is profound i mean he bore
an unbelievable burden uh and
one of the themes maybe the predominant
theme in the book uh is that he
thought you needed to lead a hard war
and then follow with a very soft peace
and
the
for a man who is not naturally himself
militaristic to be leading a hard war uh
just seemed like an extraordinarily
difficult burden to bear
one of the things that also blew my mind
was the war drags on and on for four
years and then the next election is up
1864
and people are saying to him it's like
hey you don't need to have this election
uh because you know guess what there's a
war on uh and he insists on having the
election um but but there is a period
during which he's not
favored to win
oh he's convinced he's going to lose in
august
before the election he circulates a
letter that he has written himself
predicting his defeat
closes the envelope seals it has his
cabinet sign it
and he it's literally to to be witness
to his own silent prediction of his
defeat
and and of course things change you know
importantly sherman takes atlanta
uh which changes the tone of the war
um and and and and during this time the
democrats are running against him and
the democrats are like hey everyone if
you're tired of this war bowed us in and
then we'll have peace with the south and
all be well and you have to like you
have to hear that and be like wow that'd
be a pretty compelling
pitch uh you know after years and years
of war so like that i like and if you
can imagine if he loses that race and
the democrats are like hey we're in like
peace with the south there is no united
states of america as we know today
everything changes you know
that's the thing i mean he believes that
you know
that you have to win on the battlefield
and in uh in the election for his vision
of a magnanimous piece to work the book
is about how you win a piece right the
book is about lincoln's plan to win the
peace after winning the war in his
vision for national reconciliation and
reunification
um and and and what is so extraordinary
is he comes up with this without any
historic precedent because there's never
been a civil war on that scale before he
comes up with a basic formula that you
indicated unconditional surrender
followed by a magnanimous peace and
there were people in his time
saying look we've lost three-quarters of
a million americans
you know that
lets us have peace let's have a
cease-fire he gets brought cease-fire
offers from the confederates on at least
two occasions and he refuses them
easy political win right yeah no he
would say he would say the war is over
and we won like you feel like nine out
of 10 political leaders would take that
yeah and and they would be wrong because
what lincoln understood was that the
political will to end slavery would
evaporate yes if there was a cease-fire
before surrender which is why he'd
refuse he said i know one man desires
peace more than i but i'm unwilling to
accept a peace on such terms that would
guarantee the next war if you don't
remove the root cause of the war it's
not peace
you know and and so a just war must be
followed by a just peace but you need to
end the fundamental underlying issue
which is slavery
uh and also the idea that states have a
right to secede and so that's why an
unconditional surrender needed to be
proceed needed to precede a magnanimous
peace but even in that there were people
in his own party who want vengeance yeah
and he's saying no that's not the way we
need to build our enemies back
and and we need to you know have
political reform economic expansion move
the nation's attention westward um and
then and then cultural reintegration
which will take time moving toward a
multi-racial and majoritarian democracy
which is the thing had been
fundamentally resistant um
but but he is so farsighted and and and
where the book you know
we may get there in the conversation but
where the book ends up going is that his
vision ends up being vindicated in the
wake of the second world war where we
pursue a policy of unconditional
surrender followed by a magnanimous
peace and it works
well some of the signs of the fact that
he did want a magnanimous piece is when
he talks about
letting the confederate president
essentially leave the country be like
well you know
hopefully
someone can just make sure he gets out
because
uh he doesn't want to to execute him but
he also obviously he can't just have him
hanging around
and he tells his generals to let them up
easy let everyone go home let them keep
their horses just want to have to give
them back their families
uh which would be a very tough stance to
to
uh hold on to after years and years of
of conflict and then people all telling
you that after you win like you know we
have to
um
to punish the the
treasonous
uh
rebels
so he
presides over the end of a war that he
had opportunities to end earlier but not
unconditionally and so he's like look we
need an unconditional surrender
eventually robert e lee does capitulate
and and surrenders
um and unfortunately
uh lincoln is assassinated very very
shortly thereafter
uh it it seems like
there is uh there's no real opportunity
even to celebrate the end of the war
before people are cast in the morning
yeah
that that's exactly right and and the
magnanimous piece that lincoln had been
uh evangelizing for um that seemed to be
carrying the day i mean you know he's
assassinated five days after lee
surrendered appomattox the generous
terms of which that grant writes are
basically terms that he had received
from lincoln in their
detailed meetings
but you know one of the things that
happened was is that feeling of
magnanimity of of of we must reunite the
nation is immediately replaced by by a
feeling of revenge
so lincoln's martyrdom helps solidify
the union in some respect but it also
gets us back
ironically off
it it harms his legacy because we get
off a path of anonymity towards one of
vengeance andrew johnson is the worst
possible person to take over for him
and um and and and where lincoln had
wanted the rank and file amnesty let
them you know have their guns to shoot
crows with and their horses to plow with
he he as you said he wasn't going to
make a martyr of of jefferson davis and
the confederate leadership by hanging
them which is the traditional punishment
for treason but he also wasn't going to
let the planter class the people who
should have known better the members of
congress the courts the military who who
joined the confederacy he wasn't going
to give them amnesty right away he
wasn't going to let them get their power
back because he knew that that would end
up
being a restoration
of of the slave class even in the
absence of of slavery itself
due to the
you know 13th amendment which he passed
before he died
which is a reminder by the way that even
if rights are in front of the
constitution they don't mean anything if
they're not enforced
um you know but but it just gets us off
on precisely the wrong path and the
opposite of what lincoln wanted but you
know one of the things he did understand
you want magnanimity but you still need
accountability for leadership to proceed
reconciliation
[Music]
so he succeeded by andrew johnson who
seems positively trumpian in the
description yes he's like a grieved like
all about him him him uh like a bit of
an alcoholic it seems
um i i did not realize just what a
terrible president uh andrew johnson was
i i don't think and as a result uh then
there is something of a restoration of
the southern elite
and they
implement the
black codes
codifying various ways to make blacks
second-class citizens
in the south
it probably contributes to the rise of
the kkk
which then uh president grant uh is left
uh to stamp out when he becomes
president a few years later yeah it's a
really resonant story i i think actually
the story of reconstruction is one that
our country needs to focus on a lot more
for a bunch of different reasons
you're right about about johnson in
particular i was struck by a article
about johnson at the time uh in the
atlantic monthly which uh called him
egotistic to the point of mental disease
uh vain
there were a number of lines that
reminded me of trump in the description
yeah this feels familiar
you know it's it's the old mark twain
line history doesn't repeat but
sometimes it rhymes but you're right you
know grant gets his back on the lincoln
path he'd heard lincoln's vision for how
to win a piece consistently and the most
important thing he does as a president i
would argue is when he goes to congress
personally to lobby for
the passage of the
anti-kkk enforcement act and then has
that act enforced by a southern attorney
general
so it makes it impossible or more
difficult for for the members of kkk to
say they're suffering at the hands of
yankee you know imperialism you know or
the the southern version of that and
again they hold the leadership
accountable send them to uh prison up in
albany but but and it works i mean the
first incarnation of the kkk
is cut away um but its goal was
obviously to take advantage of a vacuum
to
use voter intimidation
violence um to reassert uh white
supremacy in the south uh and and snuff
out that early uh early incidents of
black leadership in the republican party
in the south
and and it you know
it's it's no small irony to me that the
anti-kkk enforcement act is being cited
uh in some of the cases around both
charlottesville trial that's occurred
and january 6th
that a lot of the laws that were put in
place by the civil war generation to
deal with insurrection are now being
dusted off and indeed we're intended to
be not simply backward looking but
forward-looking
but it's a reminder that we cannot take
our gains for granted one of the stats
that's so chilling to me
is that um in 1900 because this took
decades to take place you know
confederate seating on the courts and
you know you know de-prioritization of
racial reconciliation
um that in 1900 alabama had 180 000
registered black voters three years
later it had three thousand
uh it's just it's just chilling and it's
a reminder what you we cannot take our
gains for granted
you start writing this book four years
ago uh were you concerned about the
possible
disintegration of the country into like
some new civil war at that point and you
were writing about uh bringing the
country back together in 2004.
polarization has gotten so much worse
since then uh your book washington's
farewell is in large part about his
warning against hyper partisanship yeah
um i mean that this this book felt very
very relevant uh in 2022. you know
so were you concerned about some of the
things we're seeing today in 2018 when
you were even considering this book
sure
um
it's a reason that we should not only be
wary but actively resist tribal politics
we've seen how dangerous that is over
and over again and you know all my work
all my columns certainly all my books
are in different ways about the core
issue of defending democracy overcoming
hyperpartisanship and polarization
because i think that's the core problem
facing us
uh and and how to making a case for how
to do that particularly through through
the creation of a vital center and the
leaders who've exemplified that from our
past
um you know my book in 2010 was called
wing nuts about you know how the lunatic
fringe is hijacking america that was a
different approach i was playing offense
from the center but saying look look at
the extremes look at the interplay of
the extremes when you hear you know
glenn beck you gotta at the time you
need to understand the john birch
society here's the history of this stuff
so this is stuff that i've i've written
about for a long time but this is it's
fun how you're attacking it from
different angles man but continue yeah
no that's exactly but it's very
intentional
you know 100 percent and and part of the
reason i went to history isn't only
because i love history and i like
writing you know
you know sort of sort of the tactile
literary history that i like to read you
know you should always try to write the
books you want to read
um but that we can talk about
politics through the prism of our
history and it gives us perspective on
our problems and our politics it's less
polarizing whereas if i you know um and
hopefully you could reach different
people by reminding them that actually
especially around the tea party when
people try to misappropriate the
founding fathers legacies to their own
ideological and political ends and then
you say no
let's look at what actually washington's
political last assault and testament
warned us against this exactly this
polarization we need to focus on on
national unity and political moderation
um and and then lincoln
you know 80 years later is is defending
our democracy as he had said as a young
man it's a nation of free men who must
live for all time or die by suicide and
he was dealing with the thing the
founding fathers feared and he was able
to summon the right kind of leadership
to to help us
survive and and that's part of the
hopeful thing about studying the civil
war
is that we've been through far worse
before
you know we need to have courage and we
need to stop feeling so precious and and
and we'll get over this we'll get
through this but it's not going to
simply happen on its own particularly if
we allow these larger forces to continue
to divide us when it doesn't actually
represent our true character as a nation
and and that's one of the things that i
think lincoln's leadership in addition
to the example of reconciling leadership
which he basically in vance
can do for us today
[Music]
uh so
he winds up with vice president andrew
johnson who ends up taking over and
being a really subpar president in part
is like a political
uh compromise unity uh ticket
and there was part of me that really
applauded it when you first read about
it you're like oh yeah unity ticket like
he got in a democrat as well you know i
mean think about that everyone
republican president vice president uh
who's a democrat it's like oh you know
there they are um but then it ends up
biting the country and the ass when you
know like andrew johnson winds up uh
becoming president
uh so so that that was one thing that
there i mean there were so many
ingredients of this where i was like wow
like unity ticket
third-party candidate like things that
most americans now today would find
inconceivable well i you know it's one
of the reasons i love to talk to you
about this book and given you the book
is that there's so many things that i
wrote very intentionally that you know
won't resonate the same way with
everybody but you know that that was you
know
you know that was 100 one of the reasons
why i focused on these things that get
short stripped lincoln runs for
re-election on a national union unity
ticket it's the national union party
um which makes a ton of sense during
civil war and then also the fact that he
ditches his vice president you know
who's from maine think about the time
the republican party is trying to bridge
the west and the northeast right so
but hamlin's not really particularly
involved in the war and he's like he's
like hanging out in maine yeah
the vice presidents did not have a very
defined role
but then he says look you know andrew
johnson is the only southerner in the
senate who refused to secede with his
state and you know he's gotten rid of
his slaves and i want to show that we
can have a national unity tick we're
going to rebrand the republican party
and it'll be a north south balance
republican and democrat giving you know
war democrats permission to vote for
this republican ticket and it's
appropriate to a time of civil war it's
inspired it's not only politically
inspired it's sort of you know it is
inspired but i think it becomes a
cautionary tale which is one of the
reasons it hasn't happened before
because of the question of character you
know there's never been a president
assassinated before abraham lincoln so
he might even though he's gotten death
threats throughout the war he might have
not been adequately thinking of it he
may have placed too much emphasis on the
fact they knew each other as young men
in this one term in congress
when grand johnson shows up drunk to
inauguration lincoln's pretty pissed and
knows he's made a big mistake
but even the radical republicans thought
that johnson would be a bigger ally than
lincoln in fact one of them benjamin
wade said before lincoln is assassinated
we hope that you know we he said to
johnson now sometimes i hope that
lincoln will be assassinated so you can
lead us to reconstruction because they
thought johnson would be more vengeful
what they they didn't adequately
appreciate is that johnson wasn't a race
warrior he was a class warrior he was
driven by resentment towards the planter
class he was actually
incredibly bigoted and and he did
everything he could to block the
progress towards equal rights with a
really vicious venom driven by his own
resentments and insecurities and
grievances so i think that one of the
reasons we haven't seen that is because
this particular example blew up so badly
in the country's face as you say
that it provides a cautionary tale if
the character of johnson had been better
if that would conceivably happen in the
future time it does not need to end the
same way as long as
the character of the people involved are
solid and they share true goals and
values
in recent times the closest we've come
to it was the
rumored pick of joe lieberman to be john
mccain's running mate um which
apparently was a fairly serious
consideration now he
i
want to have a little scoopage on that
oh no please please get some news on
that
so so i was there when that was being
pushed and floated
so uh as some of y'all might know
my political uh history is you know i'm
always an independent i'm a centrist i'm
inspired by bill clinton's campaign for
the presidency the dlc re-centering of
the democratic party
and um uh work on his
96 re-election uh you know and you know
very very low level and then uh rudy
giuliani is running for reelection in
new york and he is a centrist sort of
third way republican urban republicanism
peter beinert did a great cover story
for the new republic called the new
progressives about all these third way
mayors
and uh and
some were you know dick reardon
l.a republican rudy republican some were
democrats like michael white in
cleveland steve goldsmith indianapolis
republican
um and it was exciting so i i worked for
for rudy's uh reelection as an advanced
man you know and then ended up becoming
his chief speechwriter before 9 11 and
through 9 11 at the age of like 27 28.
rudy runs for president no eight and i
go back briefly i met my wife um and
rudy was a very different guy than he is
now um in any case so i'm there when
mccain who's his friend is calling
around gauging weather support where
there would be support for lieberman
and uh i happened to be with him and um
he was having lindsey graham called in
and some people were freaking out
because for them the partisanship was
the most important thing or the ideology
and uh and it got sort of squelched
because they're feeling as there'd be a
revolt because the right wing didn't
like you know
mccain enough to begin with despite the
fact that he was pretty conservative he
was too much of an iconoclast to
maverick
so that was that was you know that was a
brief glimpse of what might have been
but basically the party apparatus would
never allow that which is part of the
problem in our politics right it's why
there is a need to break up the
polarization
so mccain so mccain got the
the opposite of the go-ahead sign from
the party
rudy didn't think it'd be a bad idea in
particular as i recall but but the
people around him people were you know
there's a partisan economy that people
underestimate in the most cynical
economic sense yeah people make money
off polarization and party politics it's
a big business and it totally twists
people's minds and they come up with all
sorts of ornate excuses to rationalize
it but if you go outside if the party
nominee picks somebody outside their
party it short-circuits
everything and i think you know you can
argue that maybe the johnson lincoln
example is is a reason for it but i
guarantee you not any of them are
thinking about that i know but
most of them probably aren't even aware
of it plus i mean the the problem there
wasn't the unity thing is just that
andrew johnson was the wrong guy you
know what i mean like like i said it's
like if there's like a character problem
i don't know joe lieberman well but he
he seems like a a fine
human um
you could agree or disagree but that's
not his issue yeah so i mean there are
any number of high character republicans
that i think a lot of democrats could
look up and be like do i love mitt
romney like maybe not like do i think
mitt romney's a moral human like i mean
i happen to think mitt romney's a you
know a very moral guy and so um you know
like that that that would be the litmus
test but i agree with you that there are
very powerful incentives that keep you
in one camp or another i'll tell you a
small story is a sign of this um so i
start the forward party good times and
uh and then even going to law firms and
tech providers uh they actually
specialize in either one party or the
other um and so then if you were a third
party they're like well we can't deal
with you because then like our one party
might be super mad at us and that's
where all of our bread is buttered yep
yep no and and you see this over and
over again um you know these attempts to
reinforce uh conformity it's one of the
reasons why you know the the people at
the lincoln project you know who stood
up the republicans who stood up against
donald trump showed extraordinary
courage yeah um because
all the economic pressures the political
pressures the social pressures that that
created the sense of conformity that
would verify allow people to twist what
they allegedly believed in or abandon
what they allegedly believed and solely
for the sake of party unity or access to
power or profit these people didn't do
that and and whatever you you think
about the you know whether you agreed to
screw their politics i think one of the
things that you know i've talked about
is
some extent like defending democracy
against demagoguery is is a is a is a
single-issue litmus test right you're
either in favor of democracy or you're
going to find excuses for people to try
to overturn democracy and and and that
is uh that that's a very dangerous
moment we are as a country but you know
the fact that the two parties ignore the
fact that a plurality of americans are
self-identified independents that that
number has doubled over the last 30
years that they find ornate ways to
ignore or excuse it or say it's not
really a thing they find ways to ignore
the center of their own parties i mean
in a rational political universe charlie
baker or larry hogan would be the most
logical people in the world to run for
president because they're blue state
republicans with 70 approval ratings
they don't even get looked at thought
about in any short list of republicans
uh insiders because they they commit the
sin of being pro-choice or not radical
enough on other issues it's just it
fundamentally distorts our ability to
think and reason together and the rot is
in the the political extremes and their
influence on the political establishment
to the extent where there's now no
difference between the two
and i think trump really exposed that
for a lot of people but you're exactly
right the partisan economy makes cowards
of people
yeah all of the market incentives drive
in one direction
uh i talked to a guy named miles taylor
uh the other day do you know miles is
not well personally but i know of him
certainly
well yeah so uh he shared his story
about uh
leaving trump world and he got attacked
for what seems to me to be a clear act
of patriotism and principle you know
like you think somehow you get rewarded
for
doing the right thing
instead it's actually uh you get the rug
pulled out from under you uh
nine times out of ten and get accused of
really nefarious motives and so miles
and i had a laugh about it where he was
like you know like all of my economic
incentives were to do the opposite of
what i did
yep yep and it's i'm working on a piece
right now um
uh that'll be
you know recall called you know
how ukraine broke the cult of trump and
i was very resistant to call
trumpism a call
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
you're we're writing a new book sorry
no no no no no no no no no
but but but here's the point you know
steve hassan and other people and i did
this digital series on scene called you
know reality check
you know and i've been focusing on
extremism and one of the things i've
shown it over and over again
interviewing people who've left cults
first of all that the way to get people
out of a cult is through empathy the
exact process that you and i have talked
about you need to separate them from the
day-to-day ecosystem listen
nonjudgmentally don't attack their
belief system have them talk about their
their values that they believe they back
up and then have them realize on their
own uh through usually a third party
example that there is um
that they the the president the people
they've been following have not been
living up to the values that they hold
dear and the problem with this process
is it's not particularly scalable
there's another thing that cults do
which is they
they disproportionately punish heretics
they make examples for people who leave
the cult
why the reason is is because that's the
only way to reinforce group cohesion
through fear and greed but also because
the people who leave the cult are the
people who are most dangerous to the
cult because they have credibility with
the other members so the other members
have to be taught that this person is to
be shunned and cast out that there is
something shameful about them
that dynamic is is almost written into
human nature it goes back centuries when
you study cults or any of these groups
and and that's why the people who break
away and start speaking their truth need
to be held up because they're speaking
their truth but they're so threatening
to the group cohesion and sometimes that
group cohesion itself is cynical because
it's really just based upon a foundation
of fear and greed but those impulses can
be extraordinarily powerful um so long
way of saying those are the people you
wanna you wanna hold up and admire you
know one of the great mysteries to me is
why more moderate democrats haven't
gotten behind the liz cheney's native
kinsingers of the world who are like the
principled republicans who voted for
impeachment and it's just because
there's an r next now peter meyer
you know it's like some of these people
have literally had threats against their
their lives uh and they're trying to do
the right thing
and instead of being elevated and
supported in the way you're describing
they're kind of like left out to
uh to to uh kind of bear the brunt of
what's going on with their own party
so so it's interesting i i bet like
mccain at the end of his life kenzinger
certainly and again it's a good example
of this you know that the only issue
that ultimately matters whether you're
willing to defend democracy these people
are doing the right thing yeah at the
most difficult critical time and it's
not a question of who who will look good
in the eyes of history like i'll tell
you right now that's that's not a tough
call
kinsingers and cheney's are absolutely
heroes because of what they're doing
and
and whether you agree with their
politics on policy level or not it's
really irrelevant what i think you'll
find is their donations and their public
support is probably much higher among
democrats than you'd expect maybe even
50 50 and their support among
republicans is decreased the problem is
that that's a political vulnerability
particularly in redistricting and this
gets to the heart of what i think you're
getting at
instead of when redem republicans in in
republic democratic state when democrats
in states like illinois which are
democratic states are doing
redistricting or new york you know
you'd probably if you're thinking for
the good of the country is is is not
fine not try to screw adam kinsinger or
john catko you know uh you know go go
for you know if you want to make
someone's district district more
difficult take take somebody who um
like in the least stephonically use an
example uh and and make their district
slightly more democratic so they
actually have an incentive to try to
reach out and not simply play to the
base and instead what they did is they
they exerted political pressure on
kenzinger and katco even before the maps
were completed so they just decided not
to run again yeah
it's a huge loss
it's it's so short-sighted it's it's
actually very cynical because it re it
reinforces this sort of moral
equivalence
and um
and and it is
you know i hope they stay active in
politics in particular kenzinger i'm
fairly confident he will in some way and
he certainly should those people who had
the courage to stand up
i mean if if if an attempt to overturn
an election on the basis of a lion an
attack in her capital isn't clarifying
to you is it what the hell is and i
think that's that's what's i think truly
troubling about our times
[Music]
i'm going to share a personal story john
that i'm not sure
so
i
left the democratic party
on october 4th
and i was
stunned at how mad people seemed
like i i i didn't think it was going to
be
that much of a
deal like i kind of uh so you know i
filed a paperwork and was like oh you
know if i'm starting the forward party i
should break up with the democratic
party and then i was like okay i'll do
i'll post a social media video i'll
write a blog post and uh i'll put those
out in the world like that um you know
the day before the forward party gets
announced and wow
was
that like much more of uh
you know topic for a discussion and
like being accused of all sorts of very
negative things and i was like whoa guys
and part of me was a little bit like
think guys like you know i'm still the
same person an american like you know
like i haven't suddenly become a
different person
though
two things did happen after that like
one was like the venom that was directed
towards me you know like as a human
being you do notice it you're like huh
like that like that that seems a little
much for someone who
you know like i think is like
demonstrated good goodwill towards most
people and like you know trying to try
to make positive things happen for the
country
but the second thing that happened too
is that i didn't realize myself how just
taking off a party hat actually does uh
influence your thinking like i i thought
that as someone who'd been a democrat
for you know 20-plus years you know i
was like thinking uh very much for
myself that whole time
um but
i will say that you know like just
taking that piece of paper and filing it
and saying independent like all of a
sudden my take on things did
shift in part because when democrats
were saying and doing things i didn't
associate myself with them necessarily
like it wasn't necessarily my team
anymore and so you you'd actually
interpret actions and statements
differently
i think it's such a profound point i
mean
what surprised you
was it was it that you feel that people
felt betrayed because you'd run for
office as as a democrat or your base was
maybe more self-identified progressive
than it seemed because you're at your
point you're the same person you always
have fundamentally uniting rhetoric and
you've always talked about reforming a
system in a way that's beyond partisan
politics that's never been your lens um
so what what did that come from just a
tribal sense of betrayal or or what
well i think if you're trained to see
the world as black and white or good and
bad and then if someone takes off the
team jersey then uh you're just going to
think that they're joining the other
team because you can't imagine a world
where there aren't just two teams um and
and so those were the primary
accusations i seem to get john it was
like you're going to be a republican you
know like uh you know next week or like
or you're a narcissist you're like doing
it and i just i thought to myself it's
like again this stuff like no one
declares political independence as a
path to you know
glory and power
it's the exact opposite right you know
people people make compromises in
pursuit of power by joining a team and
then all of a sudden if you see quickly
it becomes party over country
it so it was very surprising you know
like i looked at it it was it was very
hard not to be struck by it um but it
speaks to what you were saying before is
that there are these false economies uh
and
like one way they maintain cohesion is
by uh casting out anyone who like kind
of you know
publicly leaves or questions the
orthodoxy yeah and i think lincoln's
example shows us that there are
different ways to lead and there have
been examples of successful third
parties in the past and highly specific
circumstances and one of the things
you've said about forward party and i
happen to agree with the principles you
have particularly around redistricting
reform open primaries and rank choice
voting because i think you need to
change the incentive structures around
our politics and then you'll have a
politics that actually rewards problem
solving and reflects our real current
our real values as a country and our
underlying character
um is that you know you don't
necessarily need to leave your party to
to associate with forward one of the
things that fascinates me is the way
that the parties try to
diminish that simple declaration of
independence not only by closing off
political uh you know
pathways superficially despite the fact
that most you know 85 of mayorality in
the country or or nonpartisan primary
elections open primaries which is what
it should be particularly for that
office
um but the way they try to diminish
independence by saying you know you
can't co you know in some states you
can't be independent you're declined to
state you're a blank right they try to
they try to the the fundamental we
should all be thinking as the founding
fathers wished
uh
way beyond party label you know
and the party labels can be helpful at
certain times they want to reiterate you
know we have asymmetric polarization
right now there's you know i'm i think
it's important to understand the
interplay between the extremes and
people's psychology but let's not kid
ourselves about which party is more
extremist when it comes to um
members of congress and and the
incentive structures right now but that
that pendulum could easily swing the
other way over time
uh and you won't understand the loop but
we if you care about actually breaking
the cycle of vengeance and violence
which is what lincoln was about then you
need to approach politics a different
way
and and you need to think about the
politics the golden rule you know treat
other people as you would like to be
treated and that's the core value that
lincoln brought to his politics that is
that that is the flow through
because his politics don't neatly line
up with ideologies today certainly not
with party labels it's got nothing to do
with
you know that that at all
so so that's where i think lincoln
becomes a leader for for for reformers
and reconcilers uh he truly was uh a
leader for the ages uh and reading your
book made me appreciate it anew uh you
know i remembered some of it but a lot
of it was new
it's a really important work and
incredibly relevant for today um my last
question for you is actually something
that that's that you and i are sharing
um so you're going to be hosting the
fair vote awards first ever
on uh april 11th in new york uh i'm
going to be there how the heck did you
link up with fair vote i get the sense
that you also got there before
uh i did or before a lot of us uh
because you've been on this train for
for a while and for those of you who
don't know fairvote is an as a
non-profit that has been uh championing
ranked choice voting for years and years
now well an election reformer at large i
mean i've been writing about um these
issues as a columnist going back to when
i began as a columnist in 2002 i was
always an independent i've never been a
republican um
and
and i've always been really focused on
these issues of political reform and and
opening open primaries and rejection
reform because we want representative
democracy yeah barbara's under democracy
more representative results and and and
this the way the system's been rigged by
the extremes you know i just you can see
this coming everything flows from these
fundamental problems we were talking
about hyper partisanship polarization so
the people working to change the rules
to change the game are people i've i've
interviewed with i've talked about the
policies i've talked about the history
of the policies crit nova salic the
uh the former bass player for nirvana
actually was uh the honorary co-chair of
fair vote for years had a great
experience of seeing the movie lincoln
with him actually and his wife and then
going out for guinness afterwards which
was a memorable night uh but so yeah
i've followed what fair vote and and
other associate groups have done been a
big supporter of their efforts because i
agree with it as a matter of principle
and one of the blessed things about
being a columnist particularly you know
before i was editor-in-chief and
different roles i've played you know you
you get to
you get to talk about what what you care
about and one of my rules i think
because i had a background in government
is i was always interested in
i'm not gonna i i want to focus on
solutions not just focus on problems
yeah and and so the people who are
putting forward solutions i want to
highlight them and talk about them and
elevate them and fairvote's been doing
that as early as anyone so i'm i'm
looking forward to that and and you
richly deserve to be on that dais with
captain murdock and some other fun folks
yeah we're gonna have a great time that
night uh john avalon i've learned a lot
from you you are much further along this
curve than just about anyone uh and i
feel like you're
like this stealth voice of moderation
and reason and reform all rolled into
one and most people don't even realize
it because you're so good-looking
congratulations on lincoln and the fight
for peace uh such a great read super
relevant for
today's era and thank you my friend for
being here it's great
my friend it's always a pleasure to talk
to you and the last hour has been no
exception i look forward to seeing you
in person sometime soon yup have a great
time with the family i'll see you at the
fair boat awards at the latest
you got it all right man be well
[Music]
you